tomorrow the dhs secretary alejandro
mayorkas will travel to south texas for
the first time since may to meet with
those working on the front lines of the
border crisis his visit comes after he
received a scathing letter from
arizona's attorney general demanding to
know how many covet positive migrants
were released into his state since
president biden took office arizona's
attorney general who is also running for
senate mark branovich joins us now good
morning mark
good thank you ainsley for having me on
this morning you're welcome thanks for
coming in what are you seeing in arizona
that got you to the point where you
wrote that scathing letter
well what we're seeing in arizona is
going to affect the entire country
basically we've seen a record amount of
fentanyl coming into this country we've
seen a record amount of illegal
people illegally crossing our southern
border we know there's a record amount
of got aways and this is not only a
seasonal problem it's a generational
problem ainsley and it's the bite
administration is essentially
subsidizing and incentivizing people to
come here and shame on secretary
mayorkas because since he has been the
secretary of homeland security a million
people a million people have illegally
crossed our southern border just this
year in the last six months since being
secretary that's like the entire
population of joe biden's home state of
delaware in less than a year this is
having a devastating impact on our
communities ainsley why do you think
that he's okay with the border being
open why do you think he's okay with
ignoring the problem and not going down
there to see for himself
i think that you know the lesson we
teach our kids is that you know you
can't ignore a problem and hope it goes
away so i think that's part of it
secondly i think it's obviously clear
that joe biden has been hijacked by the
far left of the democratic party that
wants to radically alter this country so
let's make no mistake about it what is
happening right now
is not an accident it's intentional as
to why joe biden's doing it he might not
even know but the bottom line is this
ainsley is cartel kelly and joe biden's
allies in the senate have enabled and
empowered the cartels and we're going to
continue to see more violence in our
neighborhoods we're going to continue to
see the spread of covid because of these
numbers of people that are coming in
that are coveted positive and our
communities are being polluted by the
increase in the amount of drugs so the
fact that secretary of marcus is
actually going to the border um you know
i think the cartels are happy because
it's not every day they get to meet
their hero well you hear about the
fentanyl you hear about you hear about
the crime and now covet they're not
being many of them aren't being tested
nbc's reporting that almost 20 percent
of the
individuals that are let out by ice into
our country have coveted mark levin said
that he thinks that the borders are open
and biden's ignoring it because he wants
texas and arizona to go blue what
happens to our country if that happens
uh you know this really isn't about
politics people should understand i'm a
first generation american but you the
reason why so many people want to come
here is because we have the rule of law
you cannot have
chaos you cannot have disorder you can't
have an administration systematically
not willing to enforce the laws that's
why i have three lawsuits right now
pending against the biden administration
and their failed border policies so this
is intentional i think it's an attempt
to radically change this country not
just arizona and texas and florida it's
an attempt to radically change this
country because this is all part of the
far left's push to make this country
socialist or even communist it's all
about concentration of power in dc and
that starts with having a bunch of
people come here that their first thing
they do is break the law and the
government benefits and then they get
free health care free uh subsidized
housing think about this ainsley it is
the height of absurdity that you have
people that have crossed the border
illegally as you mentioned 20 percent
positive rates they're getting free
flights anywhere they want in the
country and yet here in other parts of
the country our kids can't even go to
school we can't even go to the local
restaurant so they're shutting down the
economy and they're letting everyone
else get free flights all over this
country it's just fundamentally unfair
to american taxpayers mark bronovich who
is the attorney general of arizona
running for scott kelly's senate seat we
wish you all the best thanks for coming
on
thank you you're welcome